[Music]
many would say that the jets had a solid
draft especially with quinn and williams
being available when they picked third
overall but all is not well apparently
in new york on friday after rounds two
and three gm mike cagnan was forced to
address questions about his future which
may be in doubt
i really like working with adam um you
know it's uh you know he has a very
clear vision what he wants
you know i think he's again as i
mentioned before he is he has a very
good sense of humor a lot of energy and
a very very like positive guy to be
around and again quite funny
that came up because at the root of
these questions about mccagnan's future
and mc cagnan separately said i'm not
going to answer questions about my job
he shouldn't have to during the draft
but it's friction between mcagnen and
gays and chris whether it's le'veon bell
and there's some indications maybe gates
didn't want bell especially not for the
money the jets paid him there is reason
to believe based upon some rumors and
rumblings and reports out there that all
is not well and and there have been
multiple reports that mcagnen could be
out as soon as this week which would
just be shocking because they could have
fired him in january with todd bowles
they kept him he helped hire adam gase
the idea that he'd be out after the
draft seems just really odd especially
the idea that a new coach could come in
and so quickly acquire enough influence
to get his own gm in there yeah well i i
you know again i think that could happen
but i think that they were probably
you know more wary of okay
you know we're too deep into the draft
process right now to change around the
whole front office and maybe hire a new
guy that doesn't have all the data of
all the players that they need so i
don't think this is terribly uncommon
you know again this is kind of and i i
saw that i believe you wrote it during
the the weekend you know this is kind of
the end of the calendar year for front
office people you know their their dirty
work is done now it's like start back at
square one and let's build back to the
2020 nfl draft so uh all the heavy
lifting's done there and a lot of times
yeah organizations don't want to make
those moves you know i'm a little
surprised i guess about these rumors you
know i like you heard them as well that
he was on the hot seat and something
could happen this week um you know up
here in the new york area i just feel
like the jets fans feel like macagnan
has gotten a little bit fortunate with
some of the players that have fallen to
him in the first round which i get uh i
think they feel like some of the roster
has not been built to their likings to a
degree you know there's tremaine johnson
who they gave a lot of money last year
and that didn't go through the right way
i just think there's been little
incidents here and there that uh for
whatever reason the jets fans don't buy
into mike mckagnen and it sounds like uh
there's there's an issue there in the
organization
here's how i look at it though if you
think the guy needs to go yeah aren't
you better off getting your new gm in
there and then
not entrusting your free agency and
draft processes to a guy you're going to
get rid of anyway that's where it
becomes very very dicey and and i think
the only way around it would be to do
what the texans did back in 2005
after that season ended they fired dom
capers and essentially
pushed charlie casterly aside and and
didn't give him much influence over the
draft but he resigned after the draft in
lieu of just cleaning house immediately
after that season ended because
ownership didn't want to look bad for
fire because if you fire both guys it's
like hey what the hell were you doing
hiring both guys but but i i still think
that if you are ready to make a major
change just make the change rip the
band-aid off because this doesn't help
adam gase if he has nothing to do with
this decision if this was something
christopher johnson the ceo of the jets
was going to do from the moment todd
bowles was fired but just wanted to wait
until after the draft it looks like gace
had something to do with it which puts
even more pressure on him to turn things
around quickly because it's going to
look like he made a power play before he
had any power well yeah but i mean again
i i mean if if they did it like right
after gates got hired too or made that
move then it would look like gace was
guilty then too you know i think no you
do it at the you you fire the gm and the
coach and you bring in a new gm and a
new head coach just like they did the
last time when they fired john itzyk and
rex ryan yeah okay yeah i i get that but
i think they just realized that they i'm
guessing this is ownership that had to
do with this they realized they had a
lot of money to spend in free agency
they were going to be aggressive players
and they didn't want to rip up the whole
scouting department and try to make a
splash in free agency with a group of
people that only had a few weeks to
really figure it out i'm guessing that's
your logic i don't know well we'll find
out macagnan's still there we'll find
out this week whether he's still
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports